two one nine two david p is the
voicemail number the Eggman called in he
apparently when i told my story the
other day of how i've read a number of
studies which say if you take if you
keep your shoes on indoors
you're basically smearing dog poop all
over your apartment like at the
microscopic level if you don't take your
shoes off you're walking around with dog
poop over your apartment and the Eggman
now apparently has been panicked by that
and he called in and tried to put his
wife on the phone to comment about how
she's not happy with how he's becoming
germaphobic i guess because of my
comments anyway here's here's the call
from the Eggman take a listen Dave my
wife thinks you make me paranoid by
doing stories about taking his shoes off
in the front door
she thinks that walking poopy shoes
through the house is nothing compared to
all the facial might and eyebrow mites
and bugs that are all over your house
and I just wanted to explain to her that
dog poop on your shoes is different than
bacteria eating mites that make us
healthier on earth face I agree so she
wants you to do a story on well here
I'll let her explain feet deep v V V
anyway Dave forget it and have a great
holiday weekend hello we were very very
close to hearing from the egg man's wife
which I think would have been
fascinating on the show and she
apparently had some agenda items for us
but in any case I didn't mean to make
anybody go crazy over the dog poop stuff
listen if you've been wearing your shoes
indoors for any length of time your
house is covered in dog poop already
right like what difference is it gonna
make unless you're going to do a full
cleaning - now stop wearing your shoes
indoors so I would say don't worry about
it - too much we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today Ireland has voted in
favor of the legalization of abortion
and a historic referendum I will also
tell you what I did in Montreal and I do
have some less than lovely stories to
tell you and much more don't miss
today's bonus show sign up at join
pakman.com or at patreon.com slash david
pakman show